النجمه روجينا تفاجئ الجمهور بستهم وفي
الف الحمد لله على السلامه خطوه جديده
للنجم الصاعد ادهم او ادم الشرقاوي وبدل
استوديو البشير شو احمد البشير في استوديو
تفاعلكم اليوم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
النجمه روجينا بتطل على الجمهور في رمضان
السنه بشكل مختلف من خلال مسلسل ستهم اللي
بتقوم ببطولته وبالطل فيه بثوب رجالي
وشخصيه وامراه صعيديه باحثه وكاشفه لقضايا
تمس المراه المصريه والعربيه العمل من
تاليف ناصر عبد الرحمن واخراج رؤوف عبد
العزيز وروجينا في بتلعب دور ستهم الست
الصعيديه اللي بعد وفاه زوجها بتدخل في
صراعات وبتضطر للتنكر في هيئه رجل لتوجه
صعوبات الحياه اللي بتقابلها والمسلسل
مستوحى من قصص حقيقيه
طبعا في حاجه
معرفش كيف الناس بتدافع عنك
حتى وانت كيف الميتين
[موسيقى]
تجملت
خلاص
خلاص ما بقتش خلقات
النسوان
والله لا كسرت اتجوز
ك
ومعنا من القاهره النجمه روجينا اهلا فيكي
معنا كل عام وانت بالف خير
وانت بخير كيفك كيفك يا ست ام اي والله
انت طالعه بدور الشخصيه يعني بلبسوا
الشخصيه صراحه انت طالعه طبعا خلينا نوضح
للمشاهدين من اللوكيشن ولسا بتصوري
ايوه بالظبط طيب عشان نشرح للمجاهدين
اللبسه هذا الان انت بتصوري فيه انت طول
الوقت قررتي في هذا المسلسل خلينا نبتدي
من الناحيه الشكليه قبل ما ندخل في الامور
الاخرى تتخلي تماما عن فكره انه الست
الحلوه اللي بتحط ميك اب اللي بتلبس حلو
اللي عامله شعرها والكلام ده كله قديش صعب
صراحه على ست انه تتخلى عن هذا كله وتظهر
بهذا اللبس يعني
لا هو صعب جدا ان ممثله
ترمي كل ده وتتخلى عن شكلها وعن انوثتها
وعن المكياج واعتقد ان كل الستات المكياج
مهم جدا جدا بالنسبه لهم بس هو انا
بالنسبه لي كان تحدي كبير قوي كممثله انه
انا هقدر اعمل دور زي ده ولا لا هوافق على
تحدياته ولا لا هتخلى عن حاجات كثيره قوي
بالنسبه لي انا ببقى حباها او مش انا بس
اي انثى يعني يعني فانا انا انا بالنسبه
لي كانت حاله جديده وانا دايما اي شخصيه
جديده
مختلفه
دايما بحب اروح لها ويبقى حاصل كده حاله
تحدي بيني وبين الشخصيه دي
واهم حاجه انا بقول انه الاخلاص يعني
البني ادم دايما لما بيخلص لاي شيء هو
بيعمله حقيقي بيوصل للناس لا هو فعلا يعني
المسلسل من وقت ما بدا وهو يعني الناس
متابعه لاحداث اللي فيه لانه كمان يمكن كل
حلقه فيها احداث جديده يعني ما في حلقه
بتعدي من غير احداث صراحه وواحده من
الاشياء اللي على طول صارت ترند قصه حلاقه
شعرك اول شيء هي صوره سربت قبل المسلسل هل
صحيح انه تسربت من داخل العمل وصارت مشكله
اه طبعا طبعا لان احنا كنا احنا يعني
بدانا التصوير وفي حلاقه الشعر ده بدري
قوي وكنا شايفين انه ده بلوف في المسلسل
يعني لما ينزل ساعه العرض كان يعني حاجه
كانت مهمه جدا جدا للمسلسل وقبل التصوير
وقبل رمضان باربع خمس ايام كده الصوره
اتصورت الحقيقه يا استاذ رؤوف عبد العزيز
نزعق جدا جدا واستيق من اللي حصل وللاسف
الصوره اتسربت من اللوكيشن لان صوره انا
واستاذ رؤوف اللي فيها ايوه
الناس كلهم بتسال انه
هل فعلا روجينا حلقت شعرها تماما ولا انتم
يعني هذه خدعه بالمكياج والاشياء هذه كلها
بصي انا مش عايزه افتكر المرحله دي من
حياتي وعايزه انساها تماما تماما لانها
مرحله الصوره على الشاشه
استاذ رؤوف خد فتره كبيره قوي قوي عشان
يقنعني بكده بس انا انا دايما بقول انه
انا تحت امر الشخصيه اللي بعملها يعني انا
وافقت ان انا البس توب الرجال ووافقت ان
انا احط العمه طول المسلسل وافقت دي كلها
تفاصيل للشخصيه فالحقيقه هو بيعمق بيعمق
فكر ستهم بيعمق فكره الست اللي رفضت انها
تكون ست
ووافقت انها تلبس طوب الرجال عشان تقدر
تاخد حقها او انها اتظلمت او انها عايزه
تنزل مجتمع عشان تشتغل وتعيش
فالحقيقه انا كنت ماشيه وراه الشخصيه مش
ماشيه ورا اي حاجه تانيه ولانه عمل
بالنسبه لي مختلف وجديد في اي حاجه كنت
بقول عليها لا اه يعني يعني حاجات الصعبه
جدا جدا لازم يتقال عليها لا كنت بقول
عليها اه مش ده بس في المسلسل لا انا كان
عندي
الصعوبات جدا جدا في اللوكيشنات التصوير
في الاماكن في الشغل واكتشفت انه انه
العمل الرجالي حقيقي صعب ومرهق جدا جدا
بالنسبه للستات يعني الست اللي بتنزل
تمتهن مهنه الراجل دي ست بمليون راجل لا
هو احنا بشكل عام احنا بمليون راجل دايما
احنا دايما احسن من الرجال بس كده يعني بس
كده هتزعلينا منك وتحسسينا ان شغل الرجال
يعني نحن ما نقدر عليه لا احنا نقدر عليه
المفروض يعني لا لا اقوى من الرجال فعلا
في طبعا احنا اقوى من الرجال وطبعا انه
ربنا خصص ست بقوه بدنيه وفكريه والست
بتقدر تعمل حاجات الراجل ما بيعملهاش يعني
الست بتحمل وتربيه وتكبر وتشتغل في نفس
الوقت انما فعلا فعلا
واذكى ههه انت عايزه تضيعيني مع الرجاله
ههه انما لا في مهن حقيقي حقيقي جسمانيا
صعبه بالنسبه للست حقيقي طيب فيعني انت
حلقتي شعرك وتقبلتي المشهد
طبعا طبعا لا هو مش مشهد واحد تعيش فتره
في حياتها لا قصدي المسلسل قصدي تقبلت
مشهدك انت
انت كانثى طبعا
لا ما تقبلتش وما كنتش ببص لنفسي في
المرايه وكانوا بيعملوا لي مكياج وانا مش
قاعده قدام المرايه خالص
انا انا كمان وانا بمثل انا انا ما بشوفش
انا ما بتفرجش على شغلي يعني انا في ناس
كتير تعملي المشهد وتروحي تتفرجي انت
كويسه ولا مش كويسه انا انا عمري ما
اتفرجت على شغلي
ما كنتش ببص على نفسي ما كنتش بقعد قدام
مرايه احنا ما بنعملش مكياج انا بترش كده
حاجه بمنتهى القلم لاني بترش بمده زي
العربيات عارفه العربيات بطش حاجه كده
بسبرتو يعني انا بحط سبيرتو على وشي عشان
ما يبقاش لون يبقى كانها الشمس همم فالشمس
لما لما البني بالظبط كده في البني ادم
لما بيبقى في الشمس ما بيبقاش لونه واحد
حته غامقه حته فاتحه لانه طبيعي طيب هو
الحقيقه يعني يا روجينا انت اتبهدلتي بدل
العمل يعني سواء يعني بتقولي
اللوكيشنات الشكل واللي بيتابعوا العمل
شايفين صراحه
الدور قديش بتقدميه من قلبك يعني ما بدي
احرق العمل بس انه في مشاهد رائعه صراحه
لك طيب خلينا نشوف يمكن بعض الاشياء اللي
كمان الناس تتكلموا عنها مثلا قصه انه
قالوا انه طبس روجينا عامله هوليود سمايل
مو لايق مع الشكل العام اللي عملته كيف
بتردي على هذا الكلام
انا عندي انا عندي في في المسلسل الحلقه
الاولى فقط هي انثى ولازم تبقى انثى جميله
جدا
وبترقص وزي ما شفنا كلنا في او بتحب لانه
ده المتنفس الوحيد اللي في المسلسل كله ان
احنا نشوفها انثى ولازم كنا نشوفها انثى
حلوه جدا وحطة مكياج احمر وحاجات كده
فده ما كانش يتعارض انما بعد كده انا
شايفه اسناني اه انا لو ممكن ناخد روجينا
صوره كامله
اعطينا ابتسامه ساحره خلابه
بلاش بلاش ههه
بلاش لان هي لما بتنزل لما بتنزل حقيقي من
من المجهود ما بيبقاش فيه حاله الاهتمام
بنفسها ولانه هي بتعيش في الشارع فتره
طويله فبنلاقي اسنانها اختلفت بتخش في
خناقه ومعركه بتنضرب في سنتها بتطير
فهي عندها مراحل كثيره قوي انما يعني انا
انا بشكر استاذ الحقيقه ناصر عبد الرحمن
لانه عامل عمل كاتب عمل جيد جدا جدا وانا
بقول انها ملحمه وانه تكريم للمراه
المصريه ولا عربيه بشكل عام
وهي يعني
ده الموضوع انت كتبت بوست عن ده الموضوع
قلتي انه يعني هو تكريم للمراه في صوره
عمل درامي ده حقيقي ده حقيقي ده لا حقيقي
وبشكر كمان استاذ رؤوف عبد العزيز لانه هو
اللي اختارني للشخصيه انا ما اختارتش هذا
العمل استاذ رؤوف هو اللي اختار الشخصيه
واختارني فيها وده كان بالنسبه لي تحدي
اصعب لاني ما اخترتش شخصيه هو مخرج شافني
في شخصيه فكان بالنسبه لي انا عايزه اثبت
له دايما انه انا قد الشخصيه اللي بعملها
فعشان كده لما كان بيحصل
بهدله في التصوير او بترمي في الرمل او
بقع او انا كنت موافقه لانه كنت عايزه
الحقيقه اقدم الشخصيه كما ينبغي
روجينا بس اخر سؤال سريعه البطوله تاخرت
انها توصل للروجينا ولا وصلت لروجينا في
الوقت الصح
ما فيش حاجه اتاخرت كله بمعاد واللي كاتبه
ربنا في معاده بيبقى احسن
واهم في التوقيت اللي بعده ربنا انا بشكر
ربنا جدا جدا على انه بعد فدوى دور فدوى
واللي انا بعتقد ان الدور ده عمل لي عند
ناس كتير حاله محبه وترند وثقه وعمري
وحاله كده يا عمري بالزبط كده
فدور خلاني اتاح لي ان انا هي مش البطوله
اتاح لي ان انا اختار ادوار انا شايفه
انها تقدمني كممثله بشكل اقوى ما اتدخلتش
ولا حاجه انا كان بعدها انحراف والان
سبتهم
لا كان بعدها بنت السلطان ثم انحراف ثم
سبتهم روجينا انت الان يعني بهذا العمل
احس بتردي على كل احد انك انت يعني واحده
من اعظم الممثلات صراحه يعني دورك
رهيب
رهيب رهيب مشاهدك في اللي بتوثق الخساره
ادم الشرقاوي اسم سمعناه لاول مره من كم
سنه في مسلسل لعبه نيوتن اللي حقق نجاح
كبير ووقتها عامل ما شافوا
من وقتها اليوم ادم ماشي بخطوات ثابته على
سلم النجوميه والسلم شارك في سباق رمضان
في الموسم او في المسلسل الدرامي الكوميدي
الف حمد لله على السلامه بطوله طبعا
النجمه الكبيره يسرى وطالع بدور ابنها
المسلسل بحكي قصه عيله عايشه كانت في كندا
وبيموت الزوج فبيرجعوا لمصر عشان ينفذوا
وصيته ادم كمان عنده فيلم من بطولته رح
ينزل في العيد اسمه خمس جولات بيحكي قصه
شابي حب رياضه فنون القتال المختلطه ام ام
اي وبيخوض رحله مليئه بالتحديات والفيلم
هو اول فيلم مصري بيحكي عن هذه الرياضه
وبيحكي كمان عن حياه مغنيين الرب
عندنا حد غريب في البيت وانا مش واخد بالي
ولا حاجه
حبيتك من الاول
اتفضل معايا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره الفنان ادم الشرقاوي اهلا فيك
معانا يا ادم كل عام وانت بخير
كيف رمضان معك خلاص صرت متعود انه كذا كل
رمضان مسلسلات وشغل
صدقت ثاني
مره اسهل بكثير عشان كل حد حواليك بيصوم
يعني في امريكا
يعني الحمد لله
فاهم في الصيام بتبقى يعني
كمان خليني اوضح يا ادم انت طالع لسه من
مكان التصوير فانت رايح اخذ ركن ومتصور
وحاطط الكاميرا عشان تطلع معنا لسه
بتصوروا انتم
بالضبط فانا دلوقتي في الاوضه لقيت اي
حاجه كده هسند الكاميرا عليها وحطيت
التليفون وانا يعني الحمد لله شغال اهو
ممتاز طب احكي لي تجربه التعامل مع يسرا
واو اقول ايه انا مش عارف يعني الاستاذ
يسرا دي يعني انا اشتغلت معهم مهتمه
بشغلها قوي قوي اهم حاجه بالنسبه لها
الشغل يطلع حلو ومش بس ان هي تطلع حلوه بس
احنا كلنا نطلع حلو يعني
[موسيقى]
في كل حد حواليها وبجد بني ادمه يعني
جميله قوي وكيف الشغل مع ميان شايفه انها
بتسوي فيك ما نسيت طبعا وبنوجه لها كمان
تحيه وطبعا تحيه كبيره طبعا للفنان
الكبيره يسرى بس شايف انه ميان جلسه بتسوي
فيك مقالب
بتسوي فيك بتعمل فيك مقالب برانكس
اللي بيعمل مقالب شيماء سيف شيماء
[ضحك]
في حياتي
فعلا من الذي الشخصيات طب احكي لنا عن
المسلسل ادم ايش اللي عجبك في الشخصيه
وايه اللي عجبك في الشخصيه
اللي عجبني ان هو يعني وسط الهبل بيحصل
وكل حاجه البهدله وكل ده هو عائد عارف هو
عايز ايه
دلوقتي طالع خفيف كده
لما وريت المسلسل يعني عجبني وجودي في
المشاهد والمشاهد اللي انا حتى مش بتكلم
فيهم
يعني ليا لازمه انا موجود فده عجبني قوي
في الشخصيه طب بيجزي حقق نجاح كبير طبعا
من لعبه نيوتن هل كان سهل انه تعمل ادوار
تانيه بعدها والناس ما تفضل تقول لك انه
لا بيجزي بيجزي
لا بس يعني الحمد لله كمان عشان المسلسل
نجح قوي دي مش حاجه وحشه عارفين
كاني بيتزا مش بيحصل كثير
الشغلانه دي فانا يعني بالعكس انا كنت
بتضايق من الموضوع ده بس دلوقتي غيرت
تفكيري خالص يعني انا مبسوط ان الناس
عجبهم الشخصيه قوي بس دلوقتي يعني
هبتدي اركز بقى اطلع من من الحته دي حته
الاجنبي اللي بره
بالضبط كنت بدي اعلق لك عليها الشغلانه دي
انه لغتك العربيه تحسنت كمان
شكرا
ولما بركز ولما بيبقى في ورق قدامي يحفظه
بيبقى قتل بكتير برده اوكي بتحاول تقرا
عربي وكده ولا بتعرف تقرا عربي اصلا
ايوه تعلمت من قريب انا بقرا زي الاطفال
بس بقرا يعني الحمد لله باخذ وقت كتير بس
ما هي خطوه خطوه يا ادم خطوه خطوه وكله
هيكون تمام طيب عندك
نيه ترجع امريكا ادم وتجرب تاني هناك
افلام وكده ولا الفتره الجايه حتركز في
مصر
سنه 22 انا عملت فيلم
وان شاء الله هنشوف يعني السنه دي هركز
هناك قوي
بس بصراحه انا مش عارف ايه اللي هيحصل
الشغلانه دي
يعني انا مش قادر ابص لقدام قوي وافهم ايه
اللي جاي عشان انا مش عارف ايه اللي جاي
بحاول يعني الحاجات واحده واحده
يعني احنا شايفين البروم تبع خمس جولات
يعني
لا فيلم شكله متعوب عليه
مختلف تماما عن اي شيء بتقدمه
ان شاء الله
يعني الفكره جديده اول مره يعملوا فيلم
امامي في مصر
خلينا عندنا
خلينا نشوفها
اي حاجه حصل
ت يا ادم
اتبهدلت شكرا عشان
واضح جدا يعني
تستاهل الموضوع
لا طبعا طبعا انا كنت عايز اقدم احسن حاجه
فلازم يعني نتبهدل شويه عشان يعني في
الاخر ده ده ده فيلمي
لازم اهتمل بالحاجات دي بالتفاصيل لازم
ابقى جاهز ولازم اقدم احسن حاجه احنا طبعا
بنتمنى لك التوفيق يا ادم وان شاء الله
الفيلم كمان يكسر الدنيا وكل اعمالك
الجايه تكسر الدنيا طبعا بشكرك على ظهورك
معنا اليوم وحتركك ترجع للتصوير لانه عارف
انه اكيد بينادوا عليك وعليك ضغط والكلام
ده كله
فاعتذر من المخرج واعتذر من يسرا ومن كل
احد وارجعوا التصوير شكرا لك الفنان الشاب
ادم الشرقاوي شكرا لك
من اول ما بدات اولى حلقات مسلسل سره او
سر الباتع اللي هو من تاليف واخراج خالد
يوسف بمشاركه اكثر من 60 فنان وفنانه
والجدل على المسلسل المتوقف بدايه من
الديكور الملابس مرورا بملامح بعض
الشخصيات وانتهاء بالموسيقى التصويريه
اللي بتشهد تصعيد وتطور جديد فمن اول حلقه
الناس علقت على الموسيقى وقال له انه نفس
موسيقى فيلم الريس عمر حرب ولكن طلع
المؤلف الموسيقي راجح داوود واللي هو مؤلف
موسيقى الفيلم واسمه كمان على تتر سره
كمؤلف للموسيقى التصويريه طلع الموسيقى
وقال انه ما في تشابه في الموسيقى وانه مو
نفسها وما بتتشابه معاها ابدا وكنا نحنا
استضفنا المخرج خالد يوسف في احدى حلقاتنا
من كم يوم وسالناه عن الانتقادات اللي
الناس بيقولوها ولكنه فاجئنا برد مختلف عن
كلام راجح خلينا نسمع اشكال
على موضوع الموسيقى صاروا يقولوا انه خالد
يوسف بيستعمل مقطوعات موسيقيه سبق
واستعملها في افلامه لاي درجه هذا الكلام
صحيح
كلام صحيح جدا بس يعني الناس دي بتنسى بس
انا عملت فيلم اسمه حينصر تمام هذا الفيلم
ما استخدمت ما عملتلوش مزيكا ما عملتلوش
ما جبتش موسيقاري عشان يالف له مزيكا انا
خدت مزيكا افلامي السابقه كانت فيلم خط
مزيكا فيلم العاصفه
للاستاذ كمال الطويل وخدت مزيكا ياسر عبد
الرحمن في خيانه مشروعه وعملت بيهم مزيكا
فيلم حين ميزره بالكامل فهي مزيكا افلاني
وانا مستاذن اصحابها فايه المشكله مش فاهم
انت لك في النهايه تقول والله المزيكا مش
معبره لك والله تقول والله انا
ما عجبتنيش خالص ما عجبنيش المشهد حقك
المطلق وانا حقي المطلق ان انا استخدم
المزيكا اللي انا عايزها يعني ما تقوليش
انت هتستخدمش ايه يعني انت كمشاهد وناقد
من حقك تقول ان المزيكا غير معبره غير
موحيه لم تضيف بعدا يعني كل ده من حقك لكن
مش من حقك تقول لي استخدم دي
مثل ما شفتوا المخرج خالد يوسف قال كلام
عكس كلام راجح داود فقال انه صحيح
الموسيقى استخدمها من فيلم قديم وانه هو
حر الجديد في الموضوع اليوم انه المؤلف
راجح داوود مسكت وفجاه الناس امس ببيان
حول القصه فقال انه هو تعاقد على تاليف
الموسيقى التصويريه للمسلسل وافق المخرج
على كل التعديلات والشكل النهائي للموسيقى
وسلمها في الوقت المحدد ولكنه تفاجا في
الحلقه الاولى ان الموسيقى اللي مستخدمه
كان الفها لعمل سابق وهو فيلم الريس عمر
حرب لنفس المخرج وقال انه اعترض على اللي
صار بس المخرج قال له انه ما في مشكله لان
الموسيقى من تاليفه والفيلم لخالد كمان
وتابع انه هو ما اقتنع بالحديث ولكنه سكت
علشان ما ياثر كلامه على الجمهور اللي
بيتابع العمل وانه تجاهل كل الاتهامات
اللي سمعها عنه ولكن بعدين لاحظ في موسيقى
بتستخدم في المسلسل مو من تاليفه ولا يعرف
مين الفها وهنا نزل بيان عشان يوضح اللي
جالس وقال انه هو تعود انه يحترم جمهوره
وما بيقبل انه تنسب له موسيقى هو مالفها
ولا حتى يقتبس من مؤلف اخر واعتبر اللي
صار جريمه وقال انه اللي صار ما بيجوز تحت
اي ظرف ولا اي تبرير صراحه بيان حاد
وكلامه بسيط ابدا يعني والناس صارت تتساءل
لو في خلاف او ايش اللي صاير بالضبط خالد
يوسف ماترك الناس تتسائل كثير وطلع بفيديو
على حساباته ورد في على كلام الموسيقى
خلينا نسمع اشكال
كل سنه وانتم طيبين انا طالع النهارده ارد
على استاذي الموسيقار الكبير راجح داود في
البيان اللي طلعه
استاذ راجح بيني وبينه موده وعلاقه طيبه
جدا واشتغلنا مع بعض قبل كده من اكتر من
15 سنه في المرايسه ومرحبا وكانت تجربه
جيده جدا
وذكرياتها سعيده جدا بالنسبه لي وبالنسبه
له
البيان اللي هو طلعهم ما ازعجنيش خالص ولا
ضايقني لان هو حقه حقه ان هو ينبه الجمهور
ان في مزيكا موجوده على المسلسل مش من
تاليفه حتى لا يعتقد احد ان المزيكا دي
تنسب له وصف انه لو حد فهم ان المزيكا دي
منسوبه له وهي مش بتاعته ان ده جريمه ما
وصفش اللي انا عملته بالجريمه لان ده حقي
المطلق في ان انا احط المزيكا اللي انا
احسها ملائمه للمشهد وملائمه للمود المشهد
بين وجهه نظري
الاستاذ راجح داوود لازم نبقى يعني عشان
جمهور العريض يبقى عارف برده حتى لا
يتهمني بان انا اسات ليه لان حشر الله ان
انا اسير الاستاذ راج
اداني المزيكا التصويريه بتاعه المسلسل
بعد طبعا مديته الحلقات قبلها باكتر من
شهرين كل حلقه تباعا كانت بتجهز كان بتروح
له
اداني المزيكا قبل قبل رمضان بحاجه بسيطه
بايام قليله يعني فجيت احط المزيكا على
المشاهد لقيتها غير كافيه
استخدمتها كامله يعني مش ان انا شيلت
مزيكا راجح وحطيت مزيكه حد تاني لا انا
استخدمت كل مزيكه رجع داوود لكن في مشاهد
كتير لما لقيتلهاش مايلهمها في المزيكا
اللي هو بعتها لي فاضطريت ان انا استخدم
حاجات من افلام القديمه وطبعا مبدعينها
استاذنتهم قبل ما استخدم ده ووافقه جدا
ورحبوا بكل يعني بكل سرور الاستاذ راجح لو
هو شايف ان انا استخدمت مزيكا غير مزيجته
وكان عندي وكان في مزيكا ملائمه للمشاهد
انا بدعوه لتجربه كده عشان
يمكن اطلع انا غلطان انه ياخد اي مشهد انا
حطيت عليه تامه موسيقيه مش بتاعته
ويشوف ايه المزيكا اللي هو عملها ملائمه
لهذا المشهد ويضعها على هذا المشهد
والحلقات موجوده عنده وينشر الاثنين ينشر
اللي انا حطيته وينشر اللي هو اللي هو كان
عاملها لهذا المشهد واللي هو شايفها
ملائمه ليه واشوف انا وانتم اذا كنت انا
كنت غلطان في ان انا احط مزيكه اخرى ولا
هو كان عنده حق
احمد البشير اعلامي مخرج وكوميديان عراقي
ما بنبالغ لو قلنا انه الاشهر عراقيا احمد
عنده برنامج ساخر اسمه البشير شو بداوا في
2014 وكان بيعرض على قناه عراقيه واعتبروا
احمد ازا لمحاربه الفساد والطائفيه
والتطرف في العراق لكن البرنامج منع من
العرض والان صار على قناه دي دبليو احمد
والبرنامج ممكن جدا نلمسها في اعداد
المتابعين
والمشاهدين فعلى يوتيوب اكثر من سته مليون
مشترك في قناته قريب السبعه يعني هذا غير
الملايين في حسابات احمد على مختلف
المنصات وفي رمضان البشير مكمل او بالبشير
شو تحديدا مكمل ومع المواضيع السياسيه
والاجتماعيه المواضيع الرمضانيه لها مكان
في البرنامج
[موسيقى]
مدمره
لا يوجد لديها رحمه
[موسيقى]
اجتني القوه اما بالنسبه لهوسه اللي صار
على مسلسل دفعه لندن شوف حبي
انا وراء خليني اشوف هذا المسلسل ايش بيه
باول مشهد تطلع الاميره ديانا تركض وحدها
بالشارع ويلحقوها صحفيين ومن دون كل الشقق
دخلت بشقه مال عرب يصبون اكل واول ما تدخل
تطشر الاكل ويا دخلتها بمشهد قديم متروس
راكورات وجرافيكس عاوي وبصراحه انا ما احب
المسلسلات الخياليه فبطلت
لا تكبرون الموضوع وبعدين بوسط هذا الكم
الهائل من الاعمال اللي نازله برمضان من
الطبيعي يعني يدور المؤلف او المخرج على
حدث يثير الجدل بين الناس حتى يصير ترند
حتى تصعد مشاهدات المسلسل فلو عارفين
مسلسل المهمه قلنا احداث واقعيه اكثر اهلا
بكم مشاهدينا في فقره وجبت تفسير هنا راح
نستقبل الاتصالاتكم واستفساراتكم بكوكب
الارض
الاعلام العراقي احمد البشير اهلا فيك
معنا يا احمد منورنا اخيرا في الاستوديو
الله يسلمك سنتين صار تقريبا
جمعنا والبرنامج في رمضان ما شاء الله
متالق مولع ايش المختلف في رمضان
برمضان لحد الان وشكرا على الاستضافه هذه
ورمضان كريم وكل عام وانتم بخير
برمضان غالبا تكون الاشياء السياسيه اقل
وطئه على
المتلقي من الاشياء الكوميديه والاشياء
الترفيه بسرعه
برمضان ايضا يصير الكود سياسي لانه
السياسيين صيام وهم من يصومون لازم يعني
يتجنبون الكذب ما يصير عندهم جهد عالي
علمها
اوكي
نفطر يعني احنا نحاول نسوي البرنامج بشكل
اخاف على المتلقي فاخذنا اول حلقه البرامج
الرمضانيه اللي موجوده فقط اللي هي
مسلسلات وبرامج العاديه والحلقه الثانيه
هم اكو اشياء اخرى وهكذا برمضان شويه
البرنامج اهدا بما انه يعني احنا بنتكلم
تحديدا عن رمضان والكلام هذا كله خليني بس
احط فيه تغريده قالوا انها لك ردا على
مسلسل تحديدا دفعه لندن اللي شفناك بتتكلم
عنه هذه التغريد اللي بيقول فيها انك انت
بتوجه الكلام فيها لمي العيدان وبتقول لها
انه حكيتي او حكيتي عن العراق في غيابي
يعني ايش حقيقه هذه التغريده ايش اللي
صاير والله بصراحه انا اصلا ما اعرف
بالامانه يعني وما اعرف يعني دخلت على
الاكاونت لقيت انه هذا الاشياء منشوره
فاستغربت
على اكاونتك انت لقيتها منشوره
اتاكد انهم هل احد مهكر حسابي وكاتب لهذه
ما اعتزازي بها بشخص الكريم ما اعرفها
والله بعدين دخلت على كاونتر لقيتها حاكي
اشياء بعدين معتذره بعدين حاكي اشياء وراح
انسحبت فما افتهم هاي المسكينه مشكله
الظاهر عائليه ماثر عليها وبعدين
فما شفت الموضوع يستاهل يحكي بصراحه اوكي
طيب طبعا
لها حق الرد يعني معتزاز والله ما عندي
اياه ولا اعرفها والله انا ماني مفضل
عندها كثير يعني ماشي الحال بس انه يعني
انا وانت يعني
ماشي الحال طيب بس انت برضو لها حق الرد
يعني انت تحب رغم كل شيء يعني طيب
بعدني اذا حابه تقول اي شيء يعني خليها
تقول يعني يعني
مسلسل دفعه لندن تحديدا طيب انت اتكلمت
عنه وتحدثت عن مشهد الاميره ديانا وكذا بس
تجاهلت مثلا الكلام او خلينا نقول في
الصوره الكبيره اللي صارت الخلاف على هذا
المسلسل انه تحديدا انه في عراقيات
بيشتغلوا عند شقه فيها كويتيات او فتاه
فتاه كويتيات ايش رايك في هذا الموضوع هو
انا حطيت المسلسل بالبرنامج قلت انه انا
حطيته بخانه الساي فايف شغلات
[موسيقى]
خلال اسبوع
فاحيانا يكون اكو موضوع مهم لازم نحكي عنه
واحيانا تكون اكو مثل الاسمر احنا بمرحله
ركود سياسي خلينا نسميها ماكو ذاك الاحداث
القويه الحكومه العراقيه تحكم من طرف واحد
طرف سياسي واحد شبه طرف سياسي واحد يعني
متفقين على المتحصصين نفسهم هم يحكمون اكو
حاليا نوع من
السلام بيناتهم المؤقت طبعا
فماكو احداث سياسيه حقيقيه تصير بالعراق
مقتدى الصدر من سحب هوايه برلمان يعني
هوايه ناس يعتقدون انه وجودها كلش مهم هو
ما موجود فالقصه كلش معقده والقصه كلش
حاليا بنمر المرحله ملل سياسي يعني اسميه
ما راح يستمر ما اعتقد يستمر اليوم اكو
شيء جديد صار فهو يعتمد على الحدث السياسي
وبرمضان غالبا احنا بكل رمضان اول حلقه
نشتغل مواضيع خفيفه لانه
ما يتحمل اول حلقه حلقتين بعدين وراها اذا
اكو حد السياسه اكيد الموضوع الاستضافات
صار في جدل على موضوع الاستضافات
تستضيف اصحابك بعضهم تستضيفهم تلمعهم بعض
الناس قالوا انه يعني هو يقدم لنا محتوى
سياسي وعامل فيها مناضل ومش عارف ايش
بعدين بيجيب لنا اشياء تافهه طبعا انا ما
لي دخل في التسعية طبعا يعني كيف بترد على
هذا الموضوع او كيف بتختار ضيوفك
طبعا ما تحفظ يعني
حتى انا لانه ما في احد تافه ما لازم في
احد ينقل عنه تافه ابدا يعني
المهم
اكو ثلاث معاير
البرنامج يعتمد بالاستضافات من ضمنها مثلا
انه احنا نجيب الحدث اللي موجود بهذا
الاسبوع ونجيب شخص يعلق على الحدث او يفسر
لنا الموضوع
يفكك لنا هذه الشفره اللي مدى نفتهمها
احيانا
شيء مجنون او فعل مجنون او تصرف مجنون
مثلا او مثلا حدث سياسي او حدث امني او
حدث صارت قصه معينه بالعراق مثلا ارتفاع
سعر الدولار
البنك المركزي سانت ليغو هذه الاشياء
احيانا ماكو موضوع مهم يتفسر قبل القناه
من قبل برنامج هو برنامج سياسي اجتماعي
ساخر فنانين نضيف نستضيف امبلز نستضيف
شعراء نستضيف ممثلين كل الطبقات المشترين
ونسمع من عنده مو لقاء هو استضافه يعني هي
نصف ساعه تقريبا 25 دقيقه من الحوار
اللطيف الخفيف مو عميق مو بودكاست هو ولا
طالبين بمشاعر لا يعني بس اكو شغله مهمه
اريد اقولها انه كل اللي يجون هذا
البرنامج
عجبتني مطبين في مشاعر
بسيطه يعني
كل نجوم هذا البرنامج هم شجعان بصراحه
لهذا البرنامج
من التحفظ من قبل الكثير احنا هوايه دزينا
لهم دعواته ورفضوا انه يجون لاسباب امنيه
او تتعلق بشغلهم بالعراق اوكي لانه الظهور
معك تهمه يعني يعني مو بهاي الطريقه بس
يعني هم يخافون يحسبون حساب وين يحترم هاي
القصه ايضا اشكر كل من طلع ويانا البرنامج
ووافق انه يجي او راح يجي او اجى بالماضي
لانه هاي القصه بالنسبه لي تعني للكثير
اللي هي والجمهور يعني اللي طلعوا هل
تعرضوا مثلا رجعوا سمعوا كلام او تعرضوا
المشاكل او شيء في احد منهم ذكر لك رئيس
جمهوريه السابق مثلا شاركني بفيديو مرهم
صالح ورد علي فيديو يعني كان بيناتنا
فتقصف ما يتعلق بالتبرع اللاجئين
وصارت عليها هجمه كلش كلش كبيرهم الرجل
كان دا يحكي على موضوع التبرع وده يروج
التبرع للاجئين
فصارت عليها هجمه كلش كبيره انا ذاك لانه
رد علي فقط من قبل الميليشيات المسلحه
واعلامهم
اكو اكو رئيس جمهوريه تعرض لهذا الباقين
شجعان لانه طبوا بعينهم
يعني في وسط هذا كله وقبل كذا يعني
كنت في مكانه
وعندك خسائر عائليه صراحه يعني الله
يرحمهم جميعا يعني كل اللي فقدتهم وانت
بتتعرض لتهديدات طب هذا كله ما يخليك انت
توقف للحظه وتقول طب انا ليش بسوي هذا كله
يمكن هل مستاهل الموضوع حياتي تتعرض
لتهديد وهي القصه تبلش بالمسؤوليه تجاه
الناس يعني تنتهي قصدي تنتهي بالمسؤوليه
تجاه الناس هي بلشت بالبدايه عباره عن شغف
ايصال رساله ومحاوله انه انا اوصل صوت
هؤلاء
الناس اللي ما يقدرون يوصلون اصواتهم
بعدين وصلت الى مرحله اليوم احنا امام
مسؤوليه كبيره جدا يعني
البرنامج كبرت شهرتك كبر اسمك كل هذا
الكلام بالعراق نفتقد للمؤسسات الاعلاميه
اللي هي
مو مستقله بس تنقل كل شيء ما عندها خوف من
جهه معينه وبنفس الوقت ما عندها مصلحه
واجهه معينه هم انت ممكن الواحد يقول عنك
انك انت كمان ما انت مستقل عادي قولون
استقلاليه ايضا مو يعني عدم الاستقلاله
موصف سيئه بس اقصد الاقصى درجه من
الاستقلاليه او اكثر شيء ممكن واحد يقوله
من ناحيه تكون مو حيادي وانما عنده راي ما
يتعلق
بالموضوع فالمسؤوليه صارت كبيره على
البرنامج صارت كبيره علينا فمضطرين انه
نكمل وبنفس الوقت انا والكادر فاهمين جدا
دورنا ودور المسؤوليه اللي بلقات على
عاتقنا قديش حجم الفريق اللي معاك وهل
كلكم نفس التوجه نفس يعني مثلا احيانا
تختلفوا سياسيا مثلا
هذه الخطه فقررت انه انام
جمهوريتك جمهوريه الديكتاتور اوكي طيب
لمن الان كنا بنتكلم عنها انه محسوبه
الجهات والكلام ده كله حتى انت بيقولوا
انه يعني احمد برضو مثلا تابع لجهه
الفلانيه مثلا او انك انت الامريكان كلمه
اذناب مفضله عندكم هذه كلمه اذناب
كيف ترد
يعني هي هذه التهمه انه
قصه المستقل لازم يحطوله شغله
ما يستوعبون انه اكو فريق
بالعراق يشتغل باعلام مال علاقه باي اجنده
سياسيه والى علاقه بقصه دعم يدعم للحريات
العامه ودائم للحريات الفرديه ودعم ايضا
للعلمانيه بطريقه اداره الحكم فهذا صعب
انه يستوعب على انه هذا فريق مستقل فيوضع
على اي تهمه
وبعدين قالوا امريكا قبلها طبعا اعتيادي
قطري وسعودي
تركي وكل شي بس بعدين صارت تسقيط فردي
وصلنا مرحله المانيا وامريكا انا بدي
اشكرك على هذه المقابله شكرا لك مشاهدي
لكن معنا احمد البشير اعوذ والقاكم غدا ان
شاء الله في امان الله